ah les cigales une badin la garrigue des
produits du terroir déguster assis sur
une pierre chauffé par le soleil
à condition de faire attention dans sa
soif tout l'été des tc vous aident à
éviter les pièges et les dangers qui
menacent votre bien-être et votre santé
d'aider ses partenaires de votre été je
sais pas vous mais moi quand j'étais
petit j'étais terrorisée à l'idée de me
faire mort par une vipère en promenant
dans les hautes herbes
bon ça m'est jamais arrivé mais si ça
avait été le cas est-ce que j'aurais su
quoi faire
bah non mais vous bientôt vous serez
virés sans doute déjà entendu plusieurs
trucs à faire en cas de piqûre de vipère
faire un garrot utiliser un aspivenin ou
sucer la plaie si ça se trouve vous
connaissez même une blague là dessus
alors voyons tout ça en france l'a dit
percer le seul reptiles venimeux en
liberté on la reconnaît à sa tête
triangulaire à ses crochets et à son
museau retroussées oui parce qu une
vipère ça un museau son venin contient
des protéines et des enzymes qui rendent
la morsure douloureuse abîme les tissus
et provoque des troubles de la
coagulation
il passe dans le sang environ 30 minutes
mais si vous faites membres vous serez
sans doute très content de savoir que
dans nos régions les morsures de vipères
sont très rarement mortelle mais aussi
qu'une fois sur deux la bestiole vous
mort sans injecter de venin c'est ce
qu'on appelle une morsure blanche mais
parfois l'animal injecte son venin et
les premiers signes apparaissent environ
une demi-heure après la morsure fait mal
voire très mal elle se met à gonfler et
parallèlement le rythme cardiaque
s'accélère on ressent des nausées qui
peuvent aller jusqu'au vomissements et
des diarrhées apparaissent avec eux vont
la diarrhée quand on se balade en short
et pas très conviviale bon dans le doute
et dans tous les cas voilà ce qu'il faut
faire
cette prime a voté signal
à
d'abord appelé le samu au 15 parce qu'il
va falloir aller à l'hôpital pour une
surveillance voire pour injecter un
antivenin dans le même temps il faut
rassurer la personne qui a été mordue
lui demander de s'allonger de
s'installer aussi confortablement que
possible et de rester calmes pour
ralentir la diffusion du venin plus le
coeur bat vite et plus ça se répand dans
l'organisme enlever tout ce qui entoure
le membre mordu une bague d'une
montre-bracelet ça va gonfler vaut mieux
éviter que ça sert si vous avez de quoi
la nettoyer ou encore mieux si vous avez
un antiseptique
appliquez le sur la plaie et fait un
pansement il faut que le bandage part de
la racine du manque jusqu'à son
extrémité que vous puissiez passer un
doigt entre la banque et la peau du cou
vous avez compris faut pas faire de
garons ça sert à rien et coupé la
circulation sanguine pour rien s'est
jamais une bonne idée
ensuite immobilisé le membre et mettez
le un peu en l'air pour limiter le
gonflement et si vous avez du
paracétamol comme du doliprane ou du
dafalgan fait tourner et donc pour ce
qu'il est d'aspirer le venin l'aspivénin
pour commencer c'est une espèce de
grosse seringue avec une ventouse au
bout qu'on applique sur les piqûres en
tirant sur le piston l'appel d'air faire
ressortir le venin mais les vipères un
gicleur beaucoup trop loin sous la peau
pour que ce soit efficace
donc ça marche pas et du coup sucer la
plaie et ben ça marche pas non plus pire
si par hasard vous arriviez à aspirer
quand même un peu de venin vous
risqueriez de vous empoisonner vous même
on est d'accord c'est pas le but donc
oublié de manière générale ne sucent et
pas des plaies pour finir sachez que les
vipères en plus peur de vous que vous ne
devriez avoir peur d'elle elle s'enfuit
quand elle vous entende arrivée et elle
ne mordent que pour se défendre si elles
se sentent attaqués pour éviter de les
surprendre ne soulevait pas de pierres
dans la nature et pourrait être en train
de faire une sieste juste en dessous et
éviter aussi tripoter les souches ou les
troncs d'arbres même si vous aimez
beaucoup sa dernière chose si vous
croisez une vipère
ne la tuez pas c'est une espèce protégée
voilà se détester spécialité est terminé
on se retrouve dans 15 jours pour une
nouvelle vidéo qui sent bon le soleil
d'ici là faites vous plaisir et portez
vous bien